Мунір Царру ще не знає, куди робота зі
збору сміття заведе його сьогодні.
Багато років він та його колеги
мали чітко встановлений маршрут.
Тепер він змінюється щодня.
На своєму планшеті чоловік бачить, які саме
контейнери треба спорожнити.
Інформація надходить від датчиків, встановлених
на близько1400 підземних сміттєвих контейнерах у Гаазі.
Щодня в місті викидають близько
500 тонн побутових відходів.
Однак лише деякі контейнери настільки повні,
що їх треба спорожнити.
До такого підходу довелося звикати,
однак МунІр зрозумів переваги.
Це краще, тому що треба спорожнити лише
ті контейнери, які дійсно є повними.
Це заощаджує багато часу.
Можна зробити більше і тільки те, що необхідно.
Два роки тому службі з утилізації відходів Гааги
придбала сенсорну систему фінського стартапу Enevo.
Вартість інвестиції не розкривають.
Датчики передають дані чотири рази на день.
Співробітники використовують цю інформацію,
щоб передбачити, коли контейнери будуть повні.
Компанії важливо не лише заощадити
у довгостроковій перспективі, а й мати можливість
передбачити обсяги роботи.
Є й інші причини.
Якщо смітники заповнені лише на 10, 20, 30 %,
вони не потребують спорожнення.
Очищення контейнерів лише раз на два тижні,
а не двічі на тиждень – це краще для довкілля,
менше заторів, безпечніше для авто і людей на вулиці.
Йдеться про якість обслуговування та захист довкілля.
Це основні аргументи за  встановлення
датчиків Enevo.
Наразі систему Енево скептично сприйняли
у багатьох країнах.
Однак її постачальники переконані, що
автоматизація процесу утилізації сміття
ще набуде поширення.
Ми торуємо шлях з півночі на південь.
Почали у Фінляндії та Норвегії, а нині рухаємося далі.
Врешті-решт я думаю, що "інтернет речей"
запровадять для утилізації відходів у всій Європі,
а сенсорні системи використовуватимуть
навіть  у сміттєвозах.
У Гаазі планують встановити сенсори в усіх понад
семи тисячах контейнерах по місту.
Попри підвищення продуктивності роботи завдяки
датчикам, планів скорочувати персонал немає.
Царру і його колеги не хвилюються.
У них ще достатньо роботи.
Система фіксує, де ви перебуваєте, від місця до місця.
Можна спостерігати на моніторі в режимі реального
часу, які контейнери я обслужив, а які ні.
Це заощаджує час і зусилля.
А місто не викидає гроші на вітер,
обслуговуючи напівпорожні контейнери.